you probably know a lot of the next
steps you need to do like I realize like
there's still other strategies you're
still working it out but you know that
you need to go post that next video you
know that you need to sit down and maybe
study design for a while like learn how
to actually use canva and maybe take a
skillshare course or Join one of our
programs get our YouTube starter kit and
like actually like level up your
thumbnail game like you know the simple
things you need to do the truth is
everything in YouTube is very simple but
the simplest thing is difficult friend
this is your reminder to do hard things
the best way to start a YouTube channel
is to actually start your YouTube
channel the best way to create momentum
this month on YouTube is to go shoot
your next video get it edited get it
uploaded and then multiply how many
uploads you're gonna do the best way to
get some momentum on your channel is to
sit down and get clear on your goals
again and then do the hard work of
following through on your goals a lot of
information is Flowing on the interwebs
these days all kinds of information is
out there and the information is good
and the strategies are important but you
and I both know that ultimately even the
simple things are hard because it comes
down to implementation not just
information there's a famous quote that
says success is one percent inspiration
and 99
perspiration it's the sweat it's the
getting up and being like crap my back
hurts and I don't really feel like
filming today but figuring it out
getting up and filming the videos it's
about getting up and doing the work that
it takes to learn these skills to study
your Marketplace to study your Niche or
your competitors and do some competitive
analysis take those insights and then
apply them to your content it's about
doing the hard work of doing the things
you don't want to do in your business
like setting it up properly and
eventually incorporating into an LLC and
getting your looks right and actually
tracking your numbers and doing some
stuff that you don't want to do why
because it's hard but you got to do hard
things everything in YouTube is very
simple but the simplest thing is
difficult two things number one I've had
too much coffee today number two if you
have not seen our free master class yet
you're gonna love it if you're serious
about growing your YouTube channel just
go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class